popcorn movies a match made in theatre
heaven but there was a time when this
was banned popcorn has been around for
over 8,000 years but when it hit
American streets in the mid 1800s it
took off it was cheap and could be
mass-produced on the go not to mention
it smelled amazing
it was the go-to snack at circuses
sporting events and fairs in fact the
only place you wouldn't find popcorn was
at the movies you see going to the
movies used to be a major event the only
people that went were fancy rich folks
because he had to be educated enough to
read fancy like there was even a
coat-check but there was definitely no
concession stand there was however
popcorn street vendors who set up shop
outside theaters they made a killing
selling to waiting theater goers theater
goers that started smuggling their pop
treats inside not cool early movie
theaters kindly asked patrons check
their popcorn before entering then in
1927 films started adding sound meaning
everyone went to the movies the Great
Depression followed making movies a
cheap escape huge crowds plus crunch
muffled sound equals another revenue
opportunity for theater owners by 1945
over half the popcorn consumed in
America was being eaten at the movies a
marriage that has continued ever since
to get I found the tree
you
[Music]